help them think how taking risks
risks can take their life can change
their life and
you know can take them a step ahead
[Music]
no guest point how are you doing i'm
good how are you
i am fantastic i'm so excited to share
these next 20 minutes with you to talk
about
the wonderful hybrid program that that
you're working
on as well some of the other endeavors
that you've had no to get started
i have to talk about this fun fact you
grew up wanting to be a supermodel
and talk to me a little bit about that
i knew i will uh you know okay so um
yeah when i was 14 i guess and
it was my dream i didn't realize that
it won't happen never and because i'm
not that tall yeah
um and no one told me you know um no one
told me that
but i went to an age agency in israel
called roberto which is the well-known
agency here in israel
and he accepted me also i don't know
i thought is it i think it's a joke i
don't know
but but no that's so it's so discerning
because
you know it doesn't you don't have to be
tall to be a supermodel you don't have
to be
with specific weight and hiding you know
that's what everybody's talking about
the whole me too movement you don't have
to look a certain way to be a super
model
so why is it so far fetched nowadays
you're right but 14 15 years ago
i'm not sure and now you know my age
yeah but i'm past now i know i can't be
a model
everything is right all settled down so
and now you're folk now you're focused
on doing good for the world
so no let's let's start with a little
bit about hybrid
uh this this incredible organization in
israel
the name it aims to give a little bit of
a taste into what you're trying to do
but but what is hybrid
so hybrid i'll start you know from the
beginning
it's a co-initiative between the a200
alumni association which i'm
part of and and the government in israel
and actually either and fadi
you know um initiated like five years
ago
um and thought that why not
a200 with all the connection and skills
um you know that the graduated uh of 800
alum
a200 unit can help
other people which in our situation is
arabs
in israel so why not and
so i think um today
it's something that it's more common and
people like
understand what we are doing and love
what we are doing and i think that
five years ago people not not all of
them understood
the reason and why and and the match
between the a200 and the arab
community in israel and i think
um it's a it's a great success um
because we are truly helping
the arab society um succeed
and merge into the high-tech
ecosystem and specifically into the
startups ecosystem
and yeah so now before we get deep into
the into the workings of the program and
how
tangibly that happens give me a little
bit of context into the the ecosystem
and the relationship between
you know the 8200 unit in the israel
defense forces
uh through you know the arab communities
in israel
the integration with the tech ecosystem
you know eric schmidt
the former chairman of google and now of
alphabet he he talks a lot about how
the startup nation part of the
foundation is built upon
these technological units and the army
in general where you take 18 year olds
and you give them the skills necessary
to both mature very quickly but also
professionally
to execute on on very on very
mission-driven
um mission-driven you know missions so
so
give me a little bit of context into
what's happening in israel and why is
hybrid
even relevant especially in the place
like as well because you know in other
places around the world
it might not seem very you know very
forthcoming and relevant
yeah so here in israel you know
the a200 and other um
units army units and
are helping uh their graduates
to succeed and it's a well-known
unit that you know you just need it
recorded in your
cv and and you're good to go
um and unfortunately um the arab
community are not taking part in this
play
um and i think this is where um
hybrid come into action
and actually take all the uh the value
and the skill and the networking of the
a200
that helps them to succeed
to the arab community and like sharing
the success
and this is what i would say about
hybrid like sharing the success within
those that are not i i won't say lucky
enough but
they they don't take a part in this play
and
yeah and it's affected them for sure
right so so they're they're up until now
uh you know that there is a
you know very clear distinction between
not just the israeli
the jewish israelis and the arab
communities but also within
the jewish israeli community you have
those that go to the elite technological
units
like you're mentioning they put it on
the cv and they're pretty much good to
go it's like the mit or the harvard
of the united states and then you have a
program like harvard which aims to
to connect uh other communities with
that community so what is the actual
program
how how does that actually take place
yeah so our goal is actually to build
um a diverse team i can't say
like jewish and arab and i can't say
it's something that we are
very um succeeded by now but
and what we actually do is under the
a200
alumni association there are some
accelerators and we are
acting the same as the other
accelerators but we are
aiming to find the most talented
arab arabs in israel and actually
act as a gap or you know help them
to get to get integrated into the
startup scene
and and i don't think we do something
special except
understanding and knowing who are our
audience um understand
their needs and what we need to do in
order to
to help them and get integrated into the
the startup ecosystem here in israel so
what does it take to get integrated into
the ecosystem for somebody who's growing
up
some place that is not necessarily in
the heart of tel aviv in the heart of
startup nation yet
they have all the potential all the
capabilities of being a part of the
startup nation
what does it take that you're doing
within hybrid
yeah um so i think the first
the first thing that we are trying to
help
to help with is changing their mindset
okay um those people are um
mostly coming from more conservative
um norms and way of life
and if they don't going to be like
doctors or something very uh you know
conservative
they they join the high tech but they
mostly
will join to corporates where everything
is stable
and you know without taking risks
so i think first is changing their
mindset okay
and help them think how taking risks
risks can take their life can change
their life and
you know can take them step ahead and
you know help them take part in the play
with
the the other startups play the
jewish-led arabs a
jewish startup play and second i think
um
networking it's a kind of challenge and
because of because they are not taking
part of the army
not in the elite units and other um
um i don't know other places that i
i was lucky enough to take or maybe you
um
so this is the the second thing that we
are trying to help with
and pretty much the rest is
you know launch launching your
your own startup is it's hard for
everyone jewish arabs you know
christian um but i think we are trying
to
to help them get to the to the starting
line
and from there it's like
help them as every as each and every
entrepreneur
on earth okay because it's it's still
challenging
of course so paint me the paint me the
picture what how does the life cycle of
the program work from the moment
that you know somebody may go on the
hybrid website what what is the
what is the relationship between a
participant of the hybrid program
and whether it's mentorship or soviet or
whatever
until the moment where they are perhaps
launching their own startup and
continuing to gain the support
yeah so basically we are
meeting startups um within the whole
year okay
um we are not waiting for a specific
cohort or specific event or something
like this
we are here to help this is the the
first thing that i
that it's important to to say so
yeah when they reach us out
on every platform via email i don't know
meet us
in events or through the website
and we are very welcoming and trying to
help
all of them not all of them will join
the
the action the actual accelerator of the
the course
but we are helping all of them because
we know we have a mission
okay it's our mission to help those
people
um with or without joining the
accelerator
but the accelerator the six months
program
is our main thing okay and
it's uh you know we work uh as cohorts
and each year we have six months uh
program
and the main pillars will be
the mentoring program and the contents
you know workshops sessions one-on-ones
office hours
with investors and pretty much
everything you know all all you need in
order to
to build your own startup and being
entrepreneur um
in israel um we are here for them
we are very um listening to everything
trying to help to do as much as we can
in order to to help them grow to help
them succeed
and our goal is within these six months
and to help them being able
um to reach out to investors and
raise their first round their seed round
probably um so this is our main goal
within the accelerator but
we are doing much more than that
of course it's going to be it's going to
be impossible over a 20-minute session
uh to to explain to really grasp what's
happening there but but
but i'll try so talk to me a little bit
about like
the the highlights that you've had
within the program whether they're
personal
stories that that you've come across or
people that that it has that whose lives
have been transformed by the mentorship
they've gained through hybrid
or perhaps startups that have actually
gone through the program and
and have shown that over these six
months they're able to form a startup
and actually raise capital
yeah so i can i can start with
with saying that
we are looking for you know the
cutting-edge technology startups the
talented people that we can find
in yada i think we are mainly
um focused on find
the right people that qualified
being entrepreneur in the nearly future
okay so
within the hybrid there are lots of
pivots changing
routes um a lot of things happening
within these six months
and and we have like you know i
i have a lot of story to tell but if
i need to pick one um i would pick
um mira awards one which is a one
a woman-led um um
and called mirori and
the co-founder and the ceo is mira and
she is a 2018
graduate it was the third cycle of the
hybrid
she joined as a so as a you know sole
entrepreneur she came from the business
and she has a business uh um
background with no tech technology
uh found a tech a founder and she came
with an idea
throughout the six months she changed
the idea you know
um
i i won't say five but yeah she the team
was
there was were a lot of changes within
the team
and um by the end of the program she
like launched their her startup raised
their first round now she is
preparing to their next round and she's
um i don't know
i i really want to appreciate
their their yeah their journey what is
their start
doing um it's um
ai based a beauty assistant that helps
you
um put your makeup
um and you know
pick your style based on your or your on
your
face shape um it's addictive
technology startup and very interesting
what they're doing very very cool and so
so mira awad comes in
and she comes in with with you know some
some business acumen
and and but no technology funding teams
she goes through the six-month program
by the way how intensive is this program
how often do they meet
where do they meet yeah usually once a
week
but it depends on the program stage
but i would say once a week yeah and
once and how big is the cohort
for each for each cycle
um we accept eight to ten
startups each cohort and this and is
this
in a non-profit structure or is there
equity involved how does it work
i forgot to mention yeah so we are an
ngo
and we take a no profit no equity we are
a non-profit organization
um backed by the um but the government
and other
great sponsor that taking part in our
program
yeah wonderful wonderful and and so how
many cycles have how many alumni are
there so far how many
you've mentioned that 2018 was the third
cycle of the hybrid so imagining now by
now there have been
a four or five cycles yeah now we are
in like we are in the mind of the fifth
cohort
and we have about 40 alumni
um yeah
very very cool and and so how many how
many of those alumni have actually gone
on to
to raise a seed fund or or have made a
progress towards a sustainable startup
i would say 60 wow
that's incredible yeah yeah we are on
this
statistics yeah yeah well
it sounds it sounds like you're you're
you're have great statistics
no i'd love to touch a little bit in the
little amount of time that we have left
a little bit about your experience and
your journey
you have you you've done several things
before this
um and i'd love for you to help me
understand a little bit of
why you transitioned from you know
working in the startup you know to palti
and going into the 8200 alumni
association running an accelerator it's
a very different job from
running from managing human resources
back into polity but what are
what was that experience like and what
insights
did you bring from those experiences
towards your current job
with hybrid so it's a perfect question
um yeah so first
tipari was an extremely perfect
time for me it was a startup school
um i've been with the pal like i was
with the party about four years
in hr's um position
i worked very close uh very closely to
hanamit which is the co-founder of the
party and the ceo of course
which now i really understand how
how you know he's a leader and i i
this is what i can say a perfect leader
um
why why did he say that give me give me
one thing that you're that when you
think about
about the his leadership but
so strong personality so i don't know
something even even though he was
in in the california office and we are
in the in the israeli office it was ever
it was all the time with us
okay we all the time thought what what
can we say
what can um you know we'll think of it
so yeah
strong personality um
so etipalti i was an hr manager but
i don't know as but i guess you know
that while you're working on startups
um you're doing much more than your
title
means and i was pretty much
the connector of the of the comp of the
israeli office okay
um the r d center um
i did like lots of project um
and i was lucky enough to join the party
and
you know as a 15 employee here in israel
and working with yeah working with the
core employees of the of the company
like i i was it was an amazing and
i mean it's an amazing company to work
in
and honestly and it was an amazing
period there
i love it no i can't believe that 20
minutes have gone by way too fast but
before we leave i have to put you on the
spot once
and and ask you for three words that you
would use to describe yourself
or that you're a or that anybody at
hybrid would describe you as organ would
describe you as
who is noah
yeah i think uh authenticity
this would be the first word and
purposeful
or in hebrew tactless yeah
yeah um and passionated
about things that i'm doing i love it i
love it so so now you're in the midst of
the
of the fifth cohort and how how much
time do you have left in this cohort
um so two months and a half two and a
half months
wonderful yeah and and when is the sixth
cohort going to be applying
um we will start next june
our application open starting from
early early early and january
wonderful okay so that's not too far
from now so whoever see if anybody's
listening to this
and and you know we actually had a a
wonderful live
chat with a lot of the participants from
tech to peace
uh also also a wonderful organization
that that has a wonderful mission
um and so i can i just love these
programs that are bringing communities
together and helping
and helping uh bring up some communities
through
the through the experience that other
communities have had especially in the
israeli ecosystem i think it's just
it's just inspiring and wonderful but
now at this point i want to thank you
for your generosity and for your time
and continue doing amazing work thank
you very much
thanks to you mikhail thank you of
course take care
bye